are so another month another journal
actually it's been like a month
apologies for that it's been a busy last
couple weeks and it takes a while to
edit these journals so it's just it is
what it is I do try to get these two you
may not always do it a timely manner but
I will get them to you but here it is
this is my month of April and to start
you out well will show I'm gonna show
the last clip of the March journal it'll
be all in black and white I'll cinematic
just you've got to be like okay this is
where we were before we went into April
also I have some gripes about Mortal
Kombat in a real time that I do in here
before I did my review before they
patched it so but I'm bitching about
Mortal Kombat it's pre patch but you
know it just kind of shows you how I'm
feeling in real time so there that is
but again thank you for watching these
journals and usually I use gypsy or
danger to transition into the journal
but today we will use Keita because the
cats they need some love to look at all
the hair on the pillow he also got back
from Vegas I'm back home now danger and
gypsy are really happy to see me and
have this package in the mail waiting
for me smooth the grooves so back home
back in the swing of things it's April
1st which is funny because that means I
got to start editing my March journal
also means it's April Fool's Day so I
hope you're all pranking your friends
and style also means this my dad's
birthday
yes he was born on April Fool's Day so
we're gonna tell him happy birthday
other than that my plan today is to do
jack [ __ ] because Vegas is exhausting
that's my first day back from Vegas and
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and Friday
are shazam screening and review Pet
Sematary screening and review dentist
and then get my taxes done busy so I'm
gonna relax today kind of a wild world
to wake up to I guess I got sent the
Vice on blu-ray with like trading cards
think we're just funny cuz they even
review vice so that's cool they could
give me the blu-ray for no positive or
negative review just just cuz and I
guess tomorrow there's a joker trailer
dropping I'm pumped about that and
tonight they get to see Shazam so I'm
excited about that so today's I don't
know like there have been worse
Tuesday's to wake up to it's just kind
of neat stuff all around if not
information if not movies that I'm going
to if not movies I can watch if not
trailers to look forward to
so hey happy April I have to watch his
Sam tonight
Joker trailer tomorrow finally turned on
this pretzel machine with no cut it's
all is pooling down there I think
there's like a thing here oh yeah here
we go
alright sweet alright I'm editing my
Shazam review I love this clip from the
trailer i'll also loved it in the movie
where billy batson runs off the roof and
goes she's the lightning bolt hits him
in search of the hero and flies off like
of the movies in the DC EU or whatever
you want to call it nowadays that's
gotta be my favorite shot talk to only
got a couple hours of sleep broken sleep
because the stupid called which i
suppose is a bit advantageous because I
was awake to see the Joker trailer
dropped but I do like that trailer so
I'm gonna talk about it holy [ __ ] I
think I'm getting a fever now still
editing my Joker trailer video supposed
to watch Pet Sematary tonight I might
just do a Thursday evening after I get
my taxes done Thursday's tax day that'll
be a good day taxes and and killer
zombie pets oh my god I'm so blurry
it's kind of funny pepper now they sent
me advice on blu-ray with a little car
that got a couple more packages and it's
it's vice again and wait a minute wait
for it I have another package it's
probably vice again
yeah just opened it up it's vice again I
have three copies of vice on blue right
what am I going to do with three copies
of vice what am I gonna do with this
maybe it's because I didn't review it
and they're like please review it you
know what I got other [ __ ] to do now I'm
doing a joker trailer this is the
important stuff okay Vanessa who only
watches West Anderson movies come on
but like Wes Anderson's your guy so I
was like you have to watch this trailer
for Joker and she's like are you biased
because it's the Joker I was like
probably and it's lucky things but you
have to watch it at the end of the
trailer she was like that looks really
good so we're both gonna watch this joke
remember both gonna love it so the
corner piece of the couch is like the
coveted piece like the corner and then
that's like you know the next to it but
I mean we both fight over this so I had
to get up every single time so when I
get out she steals it and so every time
I get a she will steal it and so when I
had to go at this time like a gentleman
I did the one thing I could do because
I'm sick and I knew she was still still
it I coughed on the spot and the pillow
assist you wouldn't take it and it
worked and then take it cuz I'm nice not
because you coughed really coughed all
over my face I'm gonna get sick anyway
so totally gonna get a yeah yeah yeah
you're not naked though she's not naked
and my shirt looks like I'm like
Dipsy doesn't like it
look it's it's I just won this on the
side it's official we're both sick and I
rescheduled my taxes you look really
cute sick though we have soup it's not
it's not organic vegan vegetarian so so
we have soon oh you want someone to make
you make it alright I'll make you soup
you know I like about colds is this
easier to do Joker voice oh no I just
whipped right into it like Sam a guy
simple tastes
I enjoy dynamite and gunpowder and
gasoline and you know the thing they
have in common they're cheap
my name is Jeremy Jones that's danger
and I'm gonna lick my eyeball and we
have watched the trailer for Joker
what would you say danger over 25 times
we've watched it a lot side note I just
got an email that says there will not be
a Seattle screening for Hellboy
that's not good that that points to the
possibility that the movie might suck
ass there's not a good thing the world
will know your dicks
so I'm exporting my review for Pet
Sematary I feel like it really founded
it on that review feel kind of bad about
it
I'm gonna make jokes and so hopefully
everyone still has a good time with it
but if you look at it like two minutes
is actually reviewing the movie maybe
one and a half as long as it's
entertaining I'm cool with it as long as
people are Thomas I'm cool with it but I
don't want people who feel like oh that
was a shitty review and if they do think
that I'm gonna play the sick I was sick
pity card so there's that all right so
today is dentist day take two or part
two because I had a dent
disappointment in March and I was April
have another one because they're gonna
finish up what they examine the first
time someone would go in for some
fillings and possibly a tooth crown
point is I'm scared out of my [ __ ]
mind one day I'll tell you the story of
my dentist when I was a kid he was just
a [ __ ] [ __ ] anyhow I don't want to
go so I made it
mmm half my face is numb I feel like no
if I take a shot I can be like I'll
picked up Rachel works like a temporary
crown so I go in for a couple in a
couple more weeks to get a real crown
the meantime gave me a bunch of meds and
[ __ ] I'm not here for your entertainment
yeah turns to tug of war instead I like
how this entire time I get the cameras
right here my face I'm like hey what's
up by the way he is tall and I am short
yeah so in 2008 I grew my hair out to
cosplay before I was even cause before I
knew it was called cosplay I dressed as
a joker for the premiere of The Dark
Knight or the release of The Dark Knight
it didn't go for me or anything but I
think I have to grow my hair out for
Joker I'm really excited I think we'll
survive this I've already started
looking for the costume so we prepped
meals on Sundays which means gypsy hides
today she's hiding behind the curtain
she does not like the stove this is what
happens when Vanessa leaves Ramsay just
sits there in the weights first pretty
much what gypsy does when I leave
but Ramsay for Vanessa Ramsay and now
Vanessa's here and now REM she's like
yeah whatever
now you're here so it's it's all good
like ramsey is like your basic human
being Ramsay wants what he can't have
and then when he can have it or her
lanessa things like whatever just now
you're uninterested today there was a
released a picture of a black hole
that's 500 million trillion kilometres
away the black hole it selves bigger
than our entire solar system I really
love perspective like that because it
makes me feel like or at least makes me
know gives me the perspective that we're
not that big yeah whatever problems
there are we're not big we're not
special and I find that really calming
so I love things like this just got my
taxes done my ass hurts so bad right now
my god now that I can't complain too
much I talk about movies and
entertainment for a living for god sake
so I mean I get it like you could be
worse it's like yeah you pay taxes but
also look at the rest of the picture but
it really is a cautionary tale like that
I see I feel like it's a story of our
familiar story out there of entertainers
youtubers influencers whoever who are
like great I have all this money 100% of
its mines like count on 60 70 %
generously 70% count of 60 % of it only
being yours the rest goes to the
government it's like I've seen a few
stories of you to people who did not pay
their taxes and now they're in big
trouble so that is the lesson always pay
your taxes so Star Wars Episode nine the
rise of Skywalker trailer came out today
did a video on it number one I don't
know if it's number one comment a
recurring comment in the comment section
is that the title sucks which the title
is what they needed to do though it's
like the rise let's go Walker Scott
Walker stole thing don't don't hate us
Cousy died last time so with a good
damage control which it should be called
Star Wars Episode nine damage control
but like in terms of the rise of Scott
Walker the title itself sucking
Blacktail suck don't that like don't
most Star Wars title suck like
Empire Strikes Back is the best movie
but the title sucks like if there was if
there was no Empire Strikes Back like
the Empire Strikes Back was still around
but it's called something else and
this movie was called the first-order
Strikes Back people still be like [ __ ]
that title it's terrible you know
because it's the Blanc Strikes Back it's
really generic sounding well get parts
barracks back to shitty title so it's
the Phantom Menace so is attack of the
clothes like they all suck so it's as
good as any other Star Wars title only
this time you have the word Skywalker in
it after Luke Skywalker died so at least
it has that who is he mmm-hmm so that's
my thought movie might still suck okay I
don't know I'm letting the internet know
that you're taking part in the great
Alexey ting
yeah the echoes beta [ __ ]
Vaness has been [ __ ] with this thing
for a while yeah we should stay away I
have been editing a video it's a Star
Wars video so you know this one's gonna
be nice and peaceful in the comment
sections
yeah it's about Palpatine I applied to
be at Star Wars Celebration in the
application it was like why do you want
to come and I was like I just want it
good to come see some merch and it was
like send us a couple links to videos
that you've done talking about Star Wars
and it was like my last Jedi spoiler
talk which they probably wouldn't like
and like fans versus Disney star wars
and what I see are the problem or how it
look basically they were like [ __ ] now
you don't get passes on reddit looking
up prequel memes and I'm [ __ ] dying
they're just too funny most never about
the it was a night trailer and if
they're not they're still there it's all
funny oh man
pretty hard so did my first buy Game of
Thrones premiere video and I was I was
kind of concerned about like you know
whether or not people would roll a
sponsorship because I understand
sometimes people don't like sponsorship
but it's like the way of YouTube now oh
yes even even I have noticed some like
wait a minute revenue wise that's kind
of [ __ ] is YouTube's [ __ ] me so
there's a good opportunity to work with
Stardust and so I'm like have
with it but I should have been concerned
with the possibility that I would kind
of crush Sam tarly's emotional response
to his father and brothers death into
one situation that was his father
instead of his brother because that's
the conversation in the comments section
my bad
so shaggy jokes look they're a thing in
there real funny thing is the shaggy
jokes have seen or just recycled Chuck
Norris jokes sound like 15 years time
it'll be someone else I'm probably bob
ross or levar burton pointings it'll
happen again and in 15 years after that
same jokes different person
[Music]
this album is pretty sweet good job
smooth alright so I got this thing it's
like glass thing because apparently once
you say yes to one thing from a studio
like he's some merch or something
now they send you [ __ ] I mean two out of
three ain't bad and then I have split
popcorn and then break the whole pop boy
it's like a whole thing like headphones
I guess Kevin's headphones which you
know these are going to totally rival my
my headphones this is actually the
coolest part but it's like it's a poncho
so now I can look up and slight crime
like a bunch of toothbrushes oral
hygiene is important just make sure you
get the soft tips at first it depend
tastes like crunchberries I'm gonna pour
milk in these and just eat them nmo
watch them breakable and split and enjoy
my new coaster alright so I know this is
the exact same spot unboxing thing
yesterday this was not sponsored or
given to me by a studio this was just me
because look alright I don't have a
problem you have a problem okay
just fun this edition comes with crazy
alright so it comes with like a Sega CD
case VHS of the cutscenes strung
together to be like a movie a steelbook
and of course the game for switched so
now I have ps4 versions the unbeatable
PS Vita version but I wanted on the go
so obviously switch but how rad is this
alright so this actually has little uh
it's all if you take out there's a
little holder for a switch game but now
I dropped it it has the thing to put the
CDs and which means now I naturally have
to get the Sega CD discs it's it's an
empty case that means filling it's a
natural next step
yes I'm ironically doing a video game
showing you my video game stuff I'm
doing a video game video so to speak in
front of bison another month another
therapy session which is funny because
we actually ended the therapy session
early because I guess things are fine
you know we were like I did we got to
the point where we were just sitting
there like I guess there's nothing else
to talk about so we actually ended it
like 15 minutes early maybe 20 minutes
early which I guess there are worse
things in life than ending your therapy
session early because there's really
nothing wrong with your current
situation so that was good
one thing she did say she was like you
have a retirement plan or an accountant
or a financial adviser I was like no and
she was like you need those things so
let me give you a couple numbers so I
have to call these people it's totally
true like I don't think ahead a lot of
the times and that is something I should
totally have it's not like YouTube has a
retirement plan or anything like that
and what time will come where I need to
do that time goes exponentially
exponentially faster as you get older
it's crazy
so I kind of always I see what my
grandparents were always talking about
my grandma like oh wait till you're my
age life goes faster and it totally does
it's it's like falling like he goes
faster and faster and faster until you
hit the ground and splat because you
never retirement plan
so um so that's my homework that's the
thing I got to do but yeah this is a
good therapy session though watching
Lucifer cleaning the nerd room
finally I'm a procrastinator all right I
haven't done it yet since I showed it
flat of a month or two ago
alright anyhow I'm cleaning it now this
is gonna be an all-day thing a couple
day thing it's gonna be like a week
thing and happy Easter Sunday it's
Easter so I haven't like actually
recorded more than like a couple days I
feel weird but it is Easter Sunday I'm
going to the family's house and we're
gonna is actually really chill and
low-key my sister moms like [ __ ] it
we're getting pizzas or something
because usually it's like this big posh
yours okey then here's some stuffing
however I did find a really killer key
lime pie recipe so I made key lime pie
so it'll be like pizza and key lime pie
was pretty sweet and also what in these
videos I don't show my family's faces
I just don't show my family in general
if you're wondering it's just because
like I signed on for
internet troll II and shitty comment not
that like most of the comments are
shitty most you are like really awesome
but you know there are some and like my
family didn't sign on for that like I
signed on for the best and worse that
the Internet can give me like they
didn't sign off or anything so like yeah
I just I just want to not to have any
comments aimed at them for any whatever
reason that Charlie people would think
to do so is the one I call my family
[ __ ] shirt you know oh so like I'm
chiseled through a decade or so of of
comments that they have not been forged
in the fires so to speak so I just kind
of you know protect them from that [ __ ]
so I'm gonna hang out with my family
you're probably not gonna see my family
my videos let me hang out with them I'm
Thursday I got an email know like he
should be getting Mortal Kombat in the
mail I still don't have it and it's
Monday the day before it comes out
that's like reviews are out I still
think online it was like viewers already
have this black [ __ ] I was just find
like you know this is like I never count
on getting games or anything like that
so it's just you know it is what it is I
counted on playing it when it came out
um so if they never emailed me ever
I'd be ignorant but the fact that last
Thursday they were like you're gonna
have it today now it's been like a few
days of like every time the dogs barking
like Mortal Kombat pick and there's no
package at the door
so level first fall donessa is recording
this because I actually recorded myself
driving homes was screening even think
about it people like dude that's so
irresponsible that it is so don't do
that that was really dumb with me
so now Vanessa's recording and we're
taking the dogs to a dog trainer cuz I
realize I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing decade of having them there and
they okay
dog training went really well crazy well
actually like the danger was really well
behaved didn't behaved all day like
Vanessa came home and no barking
whatsoever
it was crazy so good job danger you did
so well I'd also like to add that
everyone else is at the Avengers end
game premieres and we're watching Botox
commercials on TV and now we're watching
murder shows so I will argue while I
work I will argue that we're having a
better evening who else is sending
emails yeah
and still have MORTAL KOMBAT so just
parked about to watch Avengers end
gaming those are pretty early in the
morning it's an early screening so it's
Avengers endgame reviewing Avengers end
game and then Mortal Kombat because
Mortal Kombat 11 came out today funny
enough I just read Infinity Gauntlet
this past weekend so now I have serious
like theories I didn't have last Friday
I have now on Tuesday going into this
movie I mean Adam warlock man they tased
him at the end of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 were they not bringing him
into this because they totally should
he's pretty important to the graphic
novel we'll see what they do I'm just
saying it should totally bring out a
Morlock in if not now when
okay so I'm sitting at the edge because
in this three-hour epic when I have to
paint not if when I can just beeline it
right there these are the things I have
to think about now Gipsy's handling
prison very well soon the rebellion will
be crushed in young Skywalker will be
one of us your look is finished my
friend this is her Emperor Palpatine
pose so editing my Avengers end game
spoiler talk it's surprisingly long
which means it's gonna take a long time
to edit it all so it's it's 1:45 in the
morning
so I either stay up all night to edit it
possibly not finishing it or just
finished editing it tomorrow and upload
it tomorrow which is Friday I'd like to
have it ready to upload like just to go
live it like 6:00 a.m. but what's up
until 6:30 editing my Avengers end game
is spoiler talked video 6:30 in the
morning that is and woke up at 9:30 and
now it's uploading the life of YouTube
sorry I'm kind of bummed out and I'll
tell you here cuz anyone watching this
it's like hardcore fan you'll know what
I'm saying I'm saying it's pretty simple
actually I'm really disappointed in MK
11 like it's really grindy
and like it's the battle mechanics I
feel like are a step back they the armor
mechanics like the costumes are a step
back it's it just feels like a step back
did not have how much fun of it the
towers are a pain in the ass I don't
want to actually go in there and play
them because I'm like great grindy asked
hours for grindy ass currency that yeah
it's not as fun as X how in the [ __ ] am
I supposed to fight in these conditions
but you get like frozen and [ __ ] god
this [ __ ] game
alright so this is the fight this is
raining snowballs and I get frozen and
so I can't do jack [ __ ] - kano oh he won
because this [ __ ] game you know what
yes I will skip because [ __ ] you so kind
of a funny story uh so there's I hopped
on Mortal Kombat 11 this morning and
there was a katana tower it was a tag
battle it's really hard so I just hop on
I search for someone to do tag with me
it finds someone and we do it and we
beat it just barely he hops on his
microphone all the time ever heard this
dude's boys he goes hey man good stuff
I've been trying to beat this all
morning it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
just I don't know cracked me out because
these towers are [ __ ]
we're shopping at Home Depot but this is
the best part who doesn't think a home
alone - there's a crying Marv if I had a
nickel for every time the computer beat
me with a sliver of life left and if my
review for it isn't up by the time this
journal hits it's because I'm waiting
from the Patchett - because of like
bitching about things they'll be patched
in like a day the review will just be
obsolete so I want to see what they do
with the patch the game of Thrones
videos up which is right 10% dislikes
which is more dislikes is bigger dislike
ratio than I usually get I guess these
10% of people were like didn't like the
episode that much which I get Dothraki
just kind of got bubble sided or washed
neither here nor there Dennis that's why
that's not what's on my mind Game of
Thrones is not on my mind right now
going to the dentist to get my permanent
crown that is I don't god
my way of not making it easy for them
gave you the work yeah yeah they gave me
the works to work yeah yeah now my
tongue is tingling but I appreciate it
thank you very much
no prob you're the best well I'm numb
can't fill a thing on this side of my
face but I got my new crown in but my
god did I read that candy ball amazing
eat it all right now and then have to
come back because I ate it all so uh
like Avengers end game box-office
destroyed it made like three hundred and
fifty seven million domestically 1.2
billion worldwide and a lot of people
were theorizing and like you can't make
that much money and I used to work at
the theater so I have thoughts so I'm
about to upload a video on these
thoughts I just feel like it's a piece
of the puzzle that no one's talking
about but I'm kind of afraid people are
gonna see me as a know-it-all prick what
do you think Rick sometimes but I'm not
a know-it-all
nothing know-it-all prick I'm just I'm a
mortal kombat prick I wasn't going to do
a video today I figured I'll take a day
off just relax
I don't know watch Cobra Kai need to
watch Kovac I've watched few episodes of
Cobra Kai really liked it but then they
had to release a really crappy trailer
for a crappy Sonic the Hedgehog movie so
time to get to work because and then
they made a portal all right like I'm
shaking right now just finished Cobra
Kai season 2
like oh my god I'm saying it like this
Cobra Kai season 2 better than Game of
Thrones season 8
like I haven't had this kind of
emotional resonation from Game of
Thrones Season eight you guys got to
watch Cobra Kai man so there was that
was my month of April shorter than the
previous journal which I like but also
less travel in May I will have travel I
am going to Los Angeles so there is that
but I don't know it's just kind of fun
even when I'm editing it when I'm
talking about Game of Thrones whatnot
it's kind of funny to see my thought
process in real time I'm talking about
Mortal Kombat or Game of Thrones things
like that just it just kind of cracks me
up to retrospectively go back and edit
these so I do it for you is every bit as
much as I do it for myself I like the
fact that out there I'm gonna have 2019
just kind of chronicled I'm gonna have a
journal of it so I mean I I'm having fun
doing this I appreciate you all watching
it I appreciate everyone who doesn't
watch it as well but you know it's a
little extra for people who want to see
a little extra and as these journals do
get buried I don't know if it's
algorithm or just views because it's not
part of the review machine they don't
get as many hits so if you want to click
the like button if you liked it pass it
around on your social media that does
help me out a lot so I appreciate that
if you do that but as always if you like
what you've seen here and you've want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]